we start off with some that you know and
then have a look at something you'll
need additional tools to work with in
order to learn there not to understand
better and by the way this just
highlights this topic highlights how
three known for you know right there's a
real sort of relationship between them
when you when you do for new topics it
really helps to add your extension one
have a look at this rational polynomial
mini and denominator linear denominator
and importantly the numerator has the
same degree as the denominator okay I in
fact as you'll see later if your
experiment they have a look at some of
the exercises it won't matter if the
degree of the numerator is higher but it
needs to be at least equal okay how do I
manipulate this so can put it in a form
that I can integrate any suggestions
what could do with it
anyone confirm enough to actually set
because I heard some murmurs but have a
go what would you actually do to it
here's the clue what you really need is
to get the numerator somehow in the form
of or in terms I'd rather the
denominator okay so at the moment the
numerators in terms X I want to in terms
of 2x plus ones how many 2x plus ones
can I see in the numerator hopefully in
about two minutes you be able to tell me
why that's a useful thing to do so
here's what I'm going to do first I can
see the important part is the X right a
constant I can plus or minus constants
and they'll come out in the wash how
many 2x Plus Ones am I likely to fit
into the numerator how many of them I'm
thinking I'm going to get about one and
a half of them right not exactly because
the constants are different but let's
try that out so one and a half of those
ok now if I have one and a half of them
okay that's not exactly the same is it
it's not going to be 3x minus 2 what is
it it'll be 3x plus 3 over 2 ok so I
have extra stuff on the top stuff I'm
not meant to have I need a minus 2 there
right so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to subtract something to
compensate so then I get back to my
minus 2 what should I subtract minus 7
over 2 I think if you do the numbers
right if I take some remember to from
that you get negative 4 over 2 which is
the minus 2 that I started ok so good
I've got the numerator in terms of the
denominator and there it is now you tell
me what was the point of that why is
that it useful ready to simplify this
I i can i can do some kids were here
kinda i can separate these fractions out
that's handy okay so here's one fraction
the two xmas right here in the two x
plus one here we'll just cancel so you
get 3 over 2 okay and then you get 702
lot solve this I kept 3 over 2 you can
integrate that what's that thing on the
right hand side you integrate that what
is that going to be hmm it's going to be
a log isn't it just to make it a little
more obvious to be a large unit f dash
on F right you don't quite have that do
you right what is f here just 2x plus 1
isn't it so f dash really ought to be
too right now you can see the F dash in
f3 obviously but of course you can't
just go and put into is where you want
because convenient my x 2 here i suppose
i want to define that would turn that
into for sound alright see what I've
done now I can integrate just slap the
exxon and this of course will become 70
for long I'll sliced it great no problem
okay
again the critical step is up here and
maybe you even want to make note of this
right it's to get the numerator in terms
of the denominator okay that's what lets
you do this step which simplifies out
and gives you something you can work